an undercover sting operation on the
outskirts of pretoria police are hoping
to catch pangolin traffickers red-handed
[Music]
raymond janssen an expert on african
pangolins is posing as a dealer
hours later three men have walked into
the trap
a small pangolin is found in their car
these creatures scales are used in
traditional chinese medicine and its
meat is considered a delicacy which is
why the illegal trade in pangolins is
booming
that was a hard one
as jensen explains operations like these
are conducted every two or three weeks
[Music]
the pangolin is now a formal exhibit so
it has to be booked into the police
station not physically but on paper and
then booked out with a certain identity
number
and from here the penguin will go to the
hospital
in johannesburg and the suspects will
appear before a magistrate to face
formal charges tomorrow morning
this is a young pangolin that still
needs nursing by its mother
it would have probably only survived
another 10 days or so in captivity says
jansen
its mother is probably dead
it's a little boy
2.6 kilograms
and we let him just quickly walk around
so we can
have a quick look at the condition if
his tail drags on the floor it's trouble
if he uses all four limbs it's also
trouble because this species of pangolin
is bipedal only walking on its hind legs
so if they use all four
limbs then it's very weak
veterinarian kelsey skinner administers
anesthetic before giving the little
pangolin a full examination
her clinic has already treated 160
animals many of them in critical
condition due to dehydration deep gashes
or parasites that weaken their immune
system
pangolins are the most trafficked
mammals in the world
we've only really been monitoring
pangolin trafficking globally for about
10 years
but over the last four to five years
it's grown exponentially up to levels
that are completely unsustainable for
all eight species
and if traffic with these animals
carries on for the next two decades we
may lose all eight species of this very
unique order of mammal
an estimated one hundred thousand
pangolins are captured each year by
poachers
fortunately this little specimen has no
injuries but given its weight loss it
evidently spent a lot of time in
captivity
it will be a challenge for the animal to
get used to its new environment
but kelsey skinner is confident about
its prospects having previously helped
other pangolins of a similar age
they really are so different be it an
adult be it a youngster
they just some of them are very shy some
of them a bit more robust and give you a
bit of a hard time when you try work
with them some of them even comedians
when they go out feeding you know they
roll around and they roll and dung and
natural wild dung
and they just some of them are very shy
and it's just incredible the
the difference in their personalities
and how they come out when they feel
comfortable around us
as part of our ongoing research on
pangolins in namibia last year kelsey
prediga founded a new and unprecedented
conservation group dedicated to the
animals
the zoologist uses camera traps and
transmitters to track and study their
behavior
but they're solitary primarily nocturnal
animals
and they share their habitat with
dangerous predators all of which makes
them hard to research
as soon as i got to see them and watch
them
they were just so interesting and
fascinating they are mammals yet they
look like little dinosaurs
and a lot of these special behaviors
like a mother with a pup and things
have rarely been observed so it feels
very special to even get to watch them
the relatively little knowledge we have
about pangolins also has technical
reasons
many of the transmitters available are
too big
so kelsey prediger has approached
specialist companies with a view to
closing that data gap with custom-made
tracking devices
this transmitter was chewed by a hyena
well it was still on the pangolin
and unfortunately we lost the gps unit
and you can see why
they need to be tough
tonight kelsey pratiger and ranger saki
joseph are looking for a female
the battery for its transmitter needs
changing every three months
the animal was released nearby a year
ago and has since been supplying the
researchers with valuable data
it enables them to track how much time
the animal spent roaming the area until
it settled
they can also perform regular checks on
its health
this information is valuable to us
in understanding what factors help a
successful reintegration of an
individual
because there are a lot of
territorial conflicts with resident
pangolin
and an understanding of how they settle
in is very valuable for the future
back in south africa the little pangolin
recovering in johannesburg has now been
given a name
stephen after the policeman who rescued
him and a lot of other pangolins
every day stephen is taken outdoors into
nature for a while
also to get him used to feeding on ants
again
we aim for a target weight to six to six
and a half kilograms it's when they're
strong enough to curl up and be able to
keep themselves curled up in their
protective ball they then go to a safe
release site and get introduced into a
soft release process
but for now stephen is given water from
a bottle after his daily exercise
thanks to that care his weight is now
back up to four and a half kilos
once he's put on another two it'll be
time to say goodbye to stevie as he's
fondly known here
you